le musée gratalou est situé en plein
cœur du village de Chevreuse il expose
les grandes œuvres du peintre Guy Rachel
gratalou mais aussi les grands artistes
qui ont créé l'art contemporain dans les
années 50 et 60 comme Ladislas Kino
c'est un artiste immense c'est un
artiste très onnant d'une période un
petit peu particulière qu'on appelle la
peinture informelle la peinture
informelle c'est finalement de la
peinture qui n'est ni abstraite ni
figurative c'est une peinture à lui et
lui encore c'est quelqu'un c'était un
créateur un créateur Ladislas Kino en
était bien un puisque c'est lui qui a
inventé le concept du froissage dans les
années 40 lorsque l'artiste n'était pas
content de ses dessins il les froissait
et les mettait dans sa poche un jour en
ressortant un de ses brouillons il s'est
dit qu'il fallait en faire une œuvre
d'art il faut savoir une chose c'est que
Kino c'est aussi l'ancêtre c'est c'est
le précurseur du street art c'est lui
qui le premier à taguer ces toiles donc
vous avez ici cette boud tag qui à la
fois exprime cette technique nouvelle
qui était effectivement de taguer de
maltraiter ces toilees Ladislas Kino
était aussi un peintre engagé à travers
son art son contemporain le célèbre
Picasso a même dit de lui souci de
Ladislas Kino qui ne froise pas que des
papiers c'est un artiste
[Musique]
puissant et puis dans le jardin on
présente justement des artistes vivant
et talentueux et je vous emmène voir
Laurette sucar Laurette sucar est une
artiste pluridisciplinaire elle est à la
fois poétesse plasticienne et éditrice
de livres dans le jardin du musée elle a
recopié ses poèmes sur deux de ces
œuvres des livres d'artistes ouverts et
des grands rouleaux vous voyez le poème
est écrit sur ces rouleaux volumain hein
vous pouvez les deviner à
travers cette transparence et ce travail
de peinture absolument superbe pour les
plus curieux chaque œuvre présentée et
documentée par un podcast cette
exposition est ouverte jusqu'au 14 avril